so one of the things that an infinite
mindset provides is is a sort of a what
I would call a quiet confidence or a
calm confidence so for example if I were
to tell you there's gonna be a massive
snowstorm or a massive hurricane in next
Thursday you're right all right it's
gonna be awful it's gonna shut down work
not gonna get to work
I'm a telecommute I may take the day off
it's definitely gonna hurt a lot of
companies right gonna hurt if you're in
a it could destroy a farm right but
we've had lots of hurricanes we know how
to deal with it we know how to prepare
for it we know there's gonna be a
short-term hit and we kind of like we
know how to ride it out well most of us
live 70 to 80 years old imagine if we
lived for a thousand years this would be
like the sixth or seventh pandemic right
that we faced in our lives it we know
it's gonna hurt we know it's gonna but
we know it's gonna be over and we know
we know there's gonna be pain and we
know how to prepare for it so what an
infinite mindset provides is it helps
you see what we're going through now not
as the end but rather just part of the
journey like it's it's it's it's hard
and it's difficult but there is a light
at the end of the tunnel we're in
darkness but we know this comes to an
end we also know that life will not be
the same afterwards this is like World
War two it's like the way life was
before World War two is not what life
was like after World War two the way
that life was before this pandemic will
not be what its gonna be when we talked
about going back to normal there is no
going back to normal yeah as a friend of
mine calls it the other day which I like
we're going back to abnormal yeah yeah
it will be different we don't really
know how but this is what's really
important to remember is this is not
without precedence which is we have gone
through things before that have shaken
the business world sometimes forcing
companies out of business what do you
think the internet did I mean the
internet you know put a lot of companies
out of business who couldn't adapt to a
new business to the new change and it
created new businesses and some
businesses were for forced to adjust
some proactively and did very well
defensively and they're still trying to
figure it out streaming put all video
stores out of business didn't have to
but it did Starbucks when Starbucks
would come into a neighborhood people
would complain that Starbucks would put
mom-and-pop coffee shops out of business
actually the data shows the opposite
that when Starbucks moved into a
neighborhood mom-and-pop coffee shops
actually did better because it brought
customers and people had a groundswell
for the for the local business the ones
that went out of business were the ones
that couldn't adapt mm-hm
they still had that old ripped up couch
because they had a monopoly on coffee
shops and when Starbucks came in with
nice clean stores they simply complained
about Starbucks they went out of
business
it's like taxis complaining about uber
an app doesn't put you out of business
you can have an app to hail a taxi it's
because you have a you have to adapt for
the changing times for new technologies
new companies new competition new ways
of doing business and if you don't adapt
you die now that's not universal some
companies like video stores some
companies this is just too much to bear
and and there's there's very little we
can do but but but to think of this in
terms of what skill sets do we have what
is our why and how else can we bring
that to life it's this is way more
sudden than the internet it's way more
shocking it's way more unnerving but
it's not new in business we know how to
do this I read of I'll tell you two
stories there's a there's a restaurant
in New York City called res Dora it's a
pasta restaurant it's a relatively new
restaurant it's only been open about
nine months so they're still on you know
they're still making a name for
themselves and of course when New York
City issued the order that restaurants
could only be 50% these guys saw the
writing on the wall they could see that
this is gonna get worse so they
immediately started to adapt their
company so instead of firing off firing
all the waiters saying well we don't
need waiters anymore they changed
everybody's job so all those same
waiters are now packaging food and
organizing online orders and and call in
orders which by the way they had to
develop this is a high-end restaurant
they didn't deliver food they had to
immediately figure out how to do that
mm-hmm but the point is is everybody
kept their job because they changed
their jobs so just as the company had to
adapt the people had to adapt as well
the people
well I'm only a waiter well I got no job
for you yeah and so what we're
experiencing even in our own company
which is we're forced to adapt we you
know we do live events well that doesn't
exist anymore so I have somebody on my
team going I'm only gonna do live events
well I got nothing for you right so we
have to adapt as individuals as much as
we have to adapt as companies I tell you
of another pizzeria in Chicago of course
70% of their money came in from selling
slices well that's done yeah not
sustainable so what they recognized is
they have assets they have resources
they have a pizza oven and so what they
want what they did is they started
ordering medical-grade industrial grade
plastic that their oven was hot enough
to heat and they started making face
shields to sell to hospitals so they're
using their pizza oven to make face
shields because they can get a the oven
hot enough to melt the plastic well I
mean genius now when this is all over
they may go back to selling pizzas or
they may have two businesses
[Music]
you